I'm here right now with dr. Charles
prober from Stanford Medical School and
what we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about principles of
antibiotic prescribing that physicians
should follow when they're treating a
child or an adult with a presumed
bacterial infection and just to be clear
because this is something I see
confusion all the time in my own family
antibiotics are for bacteria very
important point
yes antibiotics are for bacteria either
approved bacterial infection or when you
really suspect is bacterial they are not
for viruses exactly very very different
things and there are other videos on the
Khan Academy about the difference
perfect so what so sorry I interrupted
you know so we're gonna the general
principles we're going to the first
general principle when you are
contemplating treating a bacterial
infection is you first have to figure
out where you think the infection is
where in the body do you think the
infection is is it in the ears is it in
the lungs is it in the blood is it in
the bones and there a variety of other
places but that is the first general
principle the second general principle
is based upon the first and that is what
are the likely bacteria that cause
infection at the site that I've been
thinking about so for example in the
ears the likely bacteria are very
limited there's only three one is called
pneumococcus pneumococcus pneumococcus
I'm going to help you spell that it PN
EU mo see you oh no I mean oh I'm sorry
oh she should be a no pneumo Co Co Co CC
us us pneumococcus pneumococcus exactly
that we if the fancy name is
streptococcus pneumonia but it's called
pneumococcus by his friends a second
bacteria is non typable for ears second
bacterial ear infections was not non
typable homophily
non typable off non typable Hamas on
typable non typable typable like that I
think it might be any in there but
that's close enough and Hamas Phyllis H
a e m ph o l is i o l is non typable
hamas and the third bacteria is called
Moraxella catarrhalis mor ax e ll a
catalyst CA t-h-e I'm sorry CA th a are
lis there's actually two hours but one's
enough for that one and that last one
perfect okay and that's abbreviated MCAT
which students love to hear em dad so
those are the three bacteria that cause
ear infections and again a second
general principle is if we think word is
to know that we're dealing with an ear
infection that's principal one second
principal what are the likely bacteria
and we've just listed those for an ear
infection then the third principle is to
know what those bacteria that we've just
listed are likely killed by what
antibiotics killed us so I and this is
probably a silly question but how do we
know right from the get-go that it is a
bacterial infection can you have a viral
ear infection a great question actually
and most ear infections do start off
with a virus sort of setting the stage
so a child has a cold caused by a virus
the virus changes the fluid dynamics in
the ear space the fluid ends up
accumulating in that so called middle
ear space that accumulated fluid is a is
a nice growth place for bacteria that
come into the ears
backwards from the pharynx not to be
confused with the larynx to be confused
with the lyrics of pharynx I think that
might be an inside joke and so it comes
into the ears from the pharynx and then
the bacteria grow and by the time the
child has symptoms that are suggesting
an ear infection the bacteria are
usually well established all right so
when people talk about ear infections
it's it's pretty much they're talking
about a bacterial infection that is
correct
cool cool all right sorry I interrupted
so that's great so there's so there's
the three bacteria that cause your
infection the third principal sticking
with your infection as an example I
think is that we have to know what are
the likely antibiotics that kill the
bacteria causing the infection at this
particular site because that's going to
help us choose it so we want to know
what antibiotics will kill the bacteria
causing infection at the site in this
case the ear infection and is the
antibiotic dependent on just the type of
bug or bacteria it is or is it also a
combination of the bug and the location
it's it depends on the bug specifically
but the sensitivity that is the
likelihood that the bacteria will be
sensitive will be killed by the
antibiotic varies from geographic
location to geographic location so it in
order to adequately treat appropriately
treat an infection in California
specifically at our Hospital Packard
Children's Hospital it's important for
us to know the sensitivity of the
bacteria in California at Packard okay
so you oh I misunderstood so when you
say in geography I mean geography like
California versus Louisiana versus you
know England as opposed to geography in
the body precisely so that's the third
principle that we need to know what we
call the local pathogen or local
bacterial sensitivities what what in
that physical locality California what
antibiotics will likely kill that
particular bacteria so that's that's the
third prince and a pathogen is just like
anything that
bad that's correct pathogen is is a word
for something which causes problems
that's a good point the fourth principle
is that we need to understand what is
referred to as drug kinetics that is how
the drug in this case antibiotic gets
around the body and in what
concentrations how much gets the
different sites of the body so in the
example that we've been using here the
ear infection we'd want to be sure to
look at antibiotics that actually get
into the ear space the middle ear space
so that they can do their thing so at
least that part of drug kinetics we need
to understand how they penetrate
different parts of the body and how are
these drugs going to be delivered are
there going to be pills or they're going
to be like IVs or injections so it
depends on the severity of the infection
and the site of infection so ear
infections generally may cause a child
misery in terms of making them cry and
cause them to have a fever but will not
make the child particularly at risk of
serious consequences so that's not a
serious infection and is treated
invariably than by an oral route a child
takes a liquid or a pill or a capsule
and that's just because it's not as
serious it's it's you don't have to even
want to inject of it if they're not
going to die from this type of thing
precisely it's not as serious so you can
you can use a different a route that
takes their time and getting the
antibiotic into the bloodstream and into
the ear
contrast that with somebody who let's
say has something called sepsis bacteria
in their blood and maybe they're in
shock their blood pressure is falling
and that's a serious infection that's a
life and shock is a medical term it's
not like shock like shock shock it's so
indicate yes so shock is is a medical
term in medical lingo shock means a very
low blood pressure insufficient blood
being pushed through the body to
maintain your vital organs and your
function so that's so understanding drug
kinetics is important one one part of
drug kinetics is
how the drugs get to the site of the
infection if they get to the site of the
infection other parts of drug kinetics
that we consider include the so called
half-life of the drug that is how long
the drug how long it takes for the drug
to be reduced by half in in the body and
that's called the half-life whether it's
two hours or four hours or 24 hours and
the reason the half-life is important is
that that helps determine how frequently
the patient is prescribed how frequently
the patient takes the medication they're
prescribed and and how long it takes
them to get kind of a the steady-state
concentration of the concentration that
you want precisely that's that's exactly
true so that knowing a half-life is
important and there's other aspects of
drug kinetics but these are the most
important ones and generally we don't
need to memorize the specific kinetics
of a drug there are books that one can
refer to for that and the dosing
recommendations for antibiotics take
into account these drug kinetic factors
so the next and the fifth of of six
general principles is that one should
anticipate as the prescribing physician
the drug adverse effects the side
effects of the drugs and the reason of
course you want to anticipate the drug
side effects is so that you can tell the
patient or the patient's family what
they might expect if the drug is having
a side effect so for example many
antibiotics cause diarrhea and it's
terrific to advise the family that their
child may develop some diarrhea so that
they won't think that that's another
problem I can't spell diarrhea sorry I
raised it yes diarrhea is a tough word
to spell actually it's dia RR hea i
think so that's so and there are many
side effects too and different side
effects for different antibiotics but
knowing and understanding the side
effects is important I also think a side
effect of
drug and antibiotic specifically is cost
so I think a prudent physician a
physician who is prudently prescribing
the antibiotics should consider cause it
would be better to use a drug that the
patient can afford that is effective
than a drug that the patient cannot
afford and oftentimes physicians have
not become familiar with some of the
extraordinary costs of these agents so
having a pharmacist that they can call
and check it out is I think valuable
very cool so my guess is that kind of a
good starting point
well there's one fine there's one final
number six of six which is a general
principle that I like to advise our
students and residents about is that
they should limit their what I call
personal formulary that is limit the
number of antibiotics that they are
likely to prescribe to their patients as
opposed to prescribing a different
antibiotic to every patient the problem
with prescribing a different antibiotic
to every patient is the physician
doesn't acquire a familiarity with the
antibiotic and in general that
familiarity translates to maybe not
doing the best thing for the hope for
the bait for the physicians whole
patient population so I think that
knowing a lot about a few antibiotics
that are key is better than knowing a
little or nothing about a lot of
antibiotics it makes it done society
I've never thought about this one that
actually makes it makes a ton of sense
right so those are the general
principles of antibiotic prescribing and
then there there are two phases when
antibiotics are prescribed one phase is
you're making a decision when the
patient first comes to your office or
the emergency department or is admitted
to the hospital and at that phase you're
making the decision based upon a
thoughtful history a physical
examination
and an analysis of of what's going on
with the patient at that point in time
but which you don't know in this
decision-making process is what the
actual bacteria is that's causing the
infection you're guessing you're
guessing based upon knowledge but you're
guessing and that's again an educated
guess and we call this phase of therapy
the empiric therapy or the initial
therapy sometimes tests are done to try
to guide that therapy cultures maybe
taken other blood tests may be done but
that is really what's driving that
initial therapy and if the initial
therapy ends up being correct that is oh
yes the patient really does have an ear
infection and they really don't have any
other problem and the bacteria that I
thought they had is probably true
because the antibiotic that I prescribed
seems to be working because they're
getting better then that's the therapy
that you continue with however if it's a
more serious infection or the patient is
not getting better
you have to reevaluate constantly and
make a decision about changing therapy
so that would be the reassessment phase
of therapy reassess with two S's and
then another way for good measure
I only be not sure there may be an extra
s in there but I'm not sure about that
yes I think there is well and the
reassessment of the therapy is based
upon allegation is doing and also there
may be laboratory tests you've obtained
that have now come back that help guide
that reassessment phase so for example
if one thought the patient had sepsis
that with shock we talked about earlier
a blood culture will have been obtained
and if the blood culture comes back
positive for a particular bacteria the
modification of therapy would optimize
to treat that particular bacteria
makes complete sense right this would
give you some information on the actual
bacteria that you're dealing with
exactly and then that would drive this
the further selection or refinement of
the antibiotics that you had originally
prescribed empirically cool cool very
neat so those are the general principles
of antimicrobial therapy that I like to
follow and advise our students and
residents to follow as they approach
their patients know that this is my life
I feel I feel vaguely vaguely and well I
have a long wait until I fully
understand all of this but good
beginning for me Lee well we hope as a
consumer that you will never need to
have this knowledge